PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
WHEN BRE'S GRANOLA BARS
WENT MISSING...
THAT WAS NICE.
WHO DID THAT?
SHE WENT ON
THE WARPATH AGAINST NICOLE.
I POURED OUT ALL
OF NICOLE'S CANNED SODAS.
I'VE BEEN DISRESPECTED,
BUT THIS WAS JUST TOO MUCH.
BUT BOTH GIRLS MANAGED
TO SET ASIDE THE DRAMA
AND TURN IN
FIERCE PHOTOS...
THAT'S IT-- YOU'RE LOVELY
LIKE THAT.
KEEP THAT POISE. LOVELY.
WHILE KIM FAILED
TO DELIVER.
I DON'T THINK THAT KIM HAS
GIVEN ME ANY AMAZING PICTURES.
KIM, WE DON'T SEE
CONSISTENCY IN YOU.
AND SHE WAS
SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
I JUST GOT BACK
FROM ELIMINATION.
INSTEAD OF BRE BEING ELIMINATED
LIKE I THOUGHT WOULD HAPPEN,
KIM GOT ELIMINATED.
I DON'T REALLY
TRUST BRE FULLY
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS
SHE'S PULLED.
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH YOU, LIKE,
STEALING
MY THINGS.
WHERE IS
YOUR STUFF AT?
YOU DRANK IT,
AND YOU STOLE IT.
THAT'S STEALING, BRE.
YOUR RED BULLS
ARE GONE.
SO IS MY GRANOLA.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO DO NOW?
I WANT YOU
TO PAY FOR IT.
I'M NOT.
SO NOW
WHAT DO WE DO?
I'M REALLY UPSET
THAT KIM LEFT.
IT'S ALWAYS BETTER
WHEN YOU HAVE, LIKE,
A GOOD FRIEND AROUND,
AND THAT'S
WHAT SHE WAS.
I'M GONNA MISS HER
IN THE HOUSE.
(sniffles)
I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE
TAKING MY STUFF.
BEING INCONSIDERATE.
BRE AND NICOLE ARE REALLY
PISSED OFF AT EACH OTHER,
ALL OVER
A FRIGGIN' GRANOLA BAR.
NOBODY SEES ME
HERE
AS A GOOD
PERSON.
AND I AM.
I KNOW
NICOLE HATES ME.
SHE DISLIKED ME
BEFORE,
BUT I KNOW
SHE HATES ME NOW.
TO KNOW THAT MY POSITION
IN THIS COMPETITION
HAS
PRETTY MUCH BEEN TARNISHED
OVER A STUPID
GRANOLA BAR--
I KNOW I'M WRONG
FOR NOT APOLOGIZING,
BUT I GUESS
I JUST DON'T CARE.
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
TWICE IN A ROW,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL?"
I'M EXTREMELY CONFUSED
BY THE ENTIRE COMPETITION.
THERE'S GIRLS HERE
THAT I THINK THAT I HAVE DONE
CONSISTENTLY BETTER THAN,
AND THEY'RE DOING
BETTER THAN ME NOW.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS
I'M STILL HERE,
AND I STILL HAVE
ANOTHER CHANCE.
TYRA MAIL!
"GEAR UP FOR SCHOOL.
"FIND OUT
AT 7 A.M.
"DRESS THE PART,
PREPPY!"
"FROM EVERY TWIG,
A FASHION MOVEMENT GROWS.
"DRESS THE PART,
MON."
PUNK."
"EAST IS WEST
AT 7 A.M.
"DRESS THE PART,
BOLLYWOOD."
WHAT IS
BOLLYWOOD?
I WAS JUST
ASSUMING HOLLYWOOD.
I DON'T KNOW.
♪♪♪
I COULD WEAR
A SKIRT.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT BOLLYWOOD IS.
I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO BE PREPPY.
I DON'T LIKE
DRESSING PREPPY.
I DIDN'T EVEN DRESS PREPPY
WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL, SO...
DO YOU NORMALLY
WEAR PUNK?
YES,
SHE DOES.
I'M
THE PUNK FAN.
I'M GOING TO THROW CLOTHES ON
AND WHATEVER-- I'M GOOD.
MAKE SURE TO WEAR
YOUR SUNGLASSES.
OKAY.
'CAUSE I KNOW THAT
THAT'S MOD.
I THINK,
OVERALL,
I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE
WHO'S NERVOUS RIGHT NOW.
GIRLS,
WELCOME TO CARNABY STREET.
I'M SIMON DOONAN
FROM BARNEY'S,
AND I'M GONNA
BE TEACHING YOU
ALL ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF LONDON FASHION.
NOW ARE YOU ALL FAMILIAR
WITH CARNABY STREET?
(crickets chirping)
(groans)
THIS IS
WHERE IT ALL STARTED.
IN THE 1960s,
FASHION EXPLODED
HERE IN LONDON,
AND THIS WAS
THE EPICENTER.
SO TODAY
YOU'RE GONNA BE LEARNING
ALL ABOUT LONDON FASHION.
YOU'RE GONNA BE TESTED
ON EVERYTHING THAT YOU LEARN,
AND IF
YOU'RE LUCKY,
YOU COULD END UP
AS A MODEL ON CARNABY STREET.
IF YOU'RE NOT,
YOU COULD END UP
DOWN WITH THE STRIPPERS
IN SOHO.
(laughing)
JUST KIDDING.
ANYWAY,
SO FOLLOW ME.
♪♪♪
SO YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING
WHERE THE HELL ARE WE?
THIS IS AN EXHIBIT
WHICH SHOWS YOU
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT TRENDS
AND IDEAS
WHICH ARE
DRIVING BRITISH FASHION.
AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE MOST FUN-- BOLLYWOOD.
IN INDIA, THERE'S A PLACE
CALLED BOLLYWOOD
WHERE THEY MAKE
ALL THE INDIAN MOVIES.
BOLLYWOOD IS
ABOUT EXCESS
AND COLOR
AND SEQUINS.
ONE OF YOU WAS INSTRUCTED
BY TYRA
TO DRESS
IN THE STYLE OF BOLLYWOOD.
I'M HAVING A LITTLE BIT
OF A HARD TIME
FIGURING OUT
WHICH ONE THAT WAS,
SO HELP ME OUT
HERE.
IT WAS ME.
OKAY.
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN GOOD
IS MAYBE
IF YOU'D CHUCK
THIS SARI AROUND YOU.
HOW DO YOU WANT ME
TO PUT THIS AROUND ME?
I'M NOT
REALLY SURE.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THIS.
UM...
(laughs)
I NEVER DO
THE RIGHT THING.
WHY DON'T YOU
JUST CHUCK THIS AROUND.
GREAT.
YOU'RE TOTALLY
BOLLYWOOD.
HERE WE ARE
AT A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CONCEPT.
HERE'S
THE PREPPY GIRL.
SHE'S SNOTTY.
SHE'S RICH.
SHE'S LOOKING DOWN
HER NOSE AT EVERYBODY.
IT IS A VERY
CONSERVATIVE LOOK.
IT'S ABOUT
TWIN SETS.
SWEATER SETS.
IT'S ABOUT
PLEATED SKIRTS.
NOW ONE OF YOU WAS TOLD BY TYRA
TO DRESS PREPPY.
NOW, NO OFFENSE,
BRE,
BUT A CROTCH-LENGTH
DENIM SKIRT
IS NOT THE LAST WORD
IN PREPPY ATTIRE.
IT'S SORT OF
PREPPIE GOES SLUTTY.
(chuckles)
SO MANY MODELS
TODAY
WALK AROUND DRESSED
LIKE HOOCHIE DANCERS.
AND THEY NEED TO BE
A LITTLE MORE CONSERVATIVE
THAN THEY
USUALLY ARE.
(punk rock playing)
GIRLS, WELCOME TO THE ANGRY,
CRAZY, MANIACAL WORLD OF PUNK.
THE THING ABOUT PUNK WAS
IT WAS A VERY VIOLENT THING.
THERE WERE GIRLS
WEARING TRASH BAGS
WITH SAFETY PINS
THROUGH THEIR CHEEKS.
ONE OF YOU WAS ASKED BY TYRA
TO DRESS PUNK.
OH, IT'S THE JAPANESE SCHOOLGIRL
ON THE END.
WELL, THIS IS
A VERY SORT OF PRISSY PUNK.
NO OFFENSE.
AS A PUNK,
JAYLA WAS A COMPLETE DISASTER.
OKAY,
GIRLS.
IT'S TIME TO GO
STARK RAVING MOD.
NOW I KNOW A LOT
ABOUT MOD.
BUT THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS
A HELL OF A LOT MORE THAN ME--
THE CREATOR
OF IT ALL,
THE EPICENTER
OF MOD-- TWIGGY.
AND
I'M HERE.
HELLO, GIRLS.
HELLO,
LOVE.
I KNOW I AM NOT MOD
AT ALL.
AND OUT POPS
TWIGGY,
WHICH MAKES IT
EVEN MORE EMBARRASSING,
BECAUSE SHE'S
A JUDGE ON PANEL.
WHO IS
THE MOD?
IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE ME, TWIGGY.
OH, DEAR.
(laughs)
DO YOU THINK MOD IS A LOOK
THAT ANY GIRL CAN DO?
OH, ABSOLUTELY,
AND IT'S SO MUCH FUN.
AND WHAT'S GREAT NOW--
OUT THERE
THERE'S
ORIGINAL STUFF
IF YOU CAN FORAGE
IN ALL THE SECOND-HAND SHOPS.
YOU'VE GOT TO THINK
BIG BELL-BOTTOMS,
MINI-MINI-MINI-SKIRT,
TINY LITTLE
JUMPERS--
FLATTEN YOUR CHEST
IF YOU CAN--
AND TRY
AND COPY THAT.
THAT'S
COMPLETELY '60s.
THEY'D BETTER GET OUT
ON THE ROAD, HAVEN'T THEY?
BETTER GET
ON THE ROAD.
IT'S TIME TO HIT THE ROAD,
GIRLS.
YOU'VE GOT FOUR GO-SEES
TO GO TO, EACH OF YOU--
ASHLEY ISHAM,
BEN SHERMAN,
PPQ,
ROBERT CARY-WILLIAMS.
NOW, GIRLS, WHEN YOU GO
TO EACH OF THESE FOUR GO-SEES,
YOU WILL HAVE TO DRESS
ACCORDING TO THEIR STYLES.
SO WHEN YOU GO TO PPQ,
YOU SHOULD WEAR A MOD OUTFIT.
WHEN YOU GO
TO ROBERT CARY-WILLIAMS,
YOU SHOULD
DRESS PUNK.
WHEN YOU GO
TO ASHLEY ISHAM,
YOU SHOULD LOOK
BOLLYWOOD.
AND TO BEN SHERMAN,
YOU SHOULD LOOK PREPPY.
EACH DESIGNER THAT YOU GO
AND SEE IS GONNA EVALUATE YOU
ON THE KNOWLEDGE
OF THEIR STYLE,
ON YOUR GENERAL APPEARANCE,
AND YOUR MODEL BOOK.
NOW WE'RE NOT
SO MEAN
THAT WE'D SEND YOU OFF
ON THESE GO-SEES
WITH JUST
WHAT YOU'RE WEARING.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
150 QUID,
OR POUNDS,
AS THEY'RE KNOWN.
GO INTO
SPITALFIELDS MARKET.
BUY WHAT YOU CAN.
GOOD LUCK.
THE STAKES ON THIS CHALLENGE
ARE GREATER THAN EVER,
BECAUSE THE WINNER
WILL RECEIVE
100 FRAMES OF THIS WEEK'S
PHOTO SHOOT,
AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE MORE FRAMES YOU HAVE,
THE MORE CHANCES YOU'LL HAVE
TO IMPRESS US JUDGES LATER.
MAPS.
I THINK
ALL THE GIRLS
WERE IN A LITTLE BIT
OF A PANIC ATTACK.
DON'T GET LOST.
I'M THINKING,
"OH, MY GOSH,"
LIKE,
"WHAT AM I GONNA DO?"
SO GET GOING.
SPITALFIELD MARKET
IS JUST A LARGE FLEA MARKET
THAT SELLS EVERYTHING
CHEAP.
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE A DRESS,
RIGHT, A REALLY SHORT ONE?
YEAH, BUT IT'S A,
LIKE A LONG SHIRT.
I KNOW IT'S A SHIRT,
BUT...
I CAN'T REALLY FIND
ANYTHING THAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
♪♪♪
WHAT'S THE SMALLEST SIZE
YOU HAVE IN THIS ONE?
THAT'S A SMALL.
- THIS ONE?
- YEAH.
PUNK. PUNK.
I CAN'T FIND NO PANTS
ANYWHERE IN HERE.
THIS IS JUST NOT WORKING OUT
FOR ME.
EVERYTHING
LOOKS BAD.
I COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING
THAT I REALLY WANTED
THAT I THOUGHT WOULD
FIT THE STYLES.
SO I'M DEFINITELY GONNA
BE PRESSED
AS FAR AS
THIS COMPETITION GOES.
♪♪♪
HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
I DEFINITELY HAVE
FOUR OUTFITS,
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
COVERING ANY OF THE BASES
OF THE STYLE THAT I'M SUPPOSED
TO BE COVERING.
NO BIG DEAL TO GET DRESSED
IN THE CAR.
YOU GOTTA DO
WHAT YOU GOTTA DO.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CRUNCHED
FOR TIME,
SO WE GOTTA
KEEP IT MOVING.
♪♪♪
WE HAVE A CHALLENGE,
AND OUR CHALLENGE IS WE HAVE
TO GO ON FOUR GO-SEES.
NOW IT'S JUST GETTING THERE
AND DOING A GOOD JOB
AND GETTING THEM
ALL DONE.
HELLO,
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
I'M JAYLA.
JAYLA-- HI, JAYLA.
COME IN.
OKAY, LET'S HAVE A LOOK
AT YOUR BOOK.
OKAY.
SO THE OUTFITS
THAT WE PICKED OUT TODAY
ARE FROM WHAT WE CALL
OUR HERITAGE LINE.
I THINK WE'LL GO
FOR THESE.
THESE ARE A GREAT
SKINNY LEG JEANS, AND...
SO THIS IS YOUR KIND OF, LIKE,
PREPPY LOOK
THAT YOU'VE COME
TODAY?
ALMOST NAVAL
THERE...
NAVAL?
...THERE
WITH YOUR STRIPED TOP.
OH, NO!
NOT PREPPY
AT ALL.
NOT AT ALL
PREPPY.
THE DESIGNER
AT BEN SHERMAN--
SHE'S,
LIKE, STUCK UP.
(sighs)
THAT'S AWFUL.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
HI,
I'M PERCY.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
I'M NIK.
NIK,
HELLO.
HI.
DID YOU MAKE THIS?
(giggles)
UM, I DID NOT
MAKE IT.
I JUST PICKED IT UP
AT A FLEA MARKET.
I WAS TRYING TO GO
FOR THAT MOD APPEAL.
MY FIRST IMPRESSION
OF NIK
WAS THAT HER DRESS
WAS REALLY QUITE BOLD.
TRYING TO ACHIEVE
A LOOK.
SHE ASKED ME
ABOUT MY OUTFIT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
BECAUSE IT WAS RIDICULOUS
OR SHE LIKED IT.
♪♪♪
HI, I'M BRE,
NICE TO MEET YOU.
I'M ASHLEY ISHAM,
OH, MY GOODNESS,
I'M SO SORRY.
I LEFT IT
IN MY CAR.
OKAY,
NO PROBLEM.
I LEFT
MY BOOK.
I WAS ACTUALLY VERY SHOCKED
THAT BRE WOULD ACTUALLY COME
TO A GO-SEE
WITHOUT A PORTFOLIO.
THIS IS
MY MOST RECENT PICTURE.
I ACTUALLY DID THAT ONE
IN LONDON.
THAT'S
A VERY GOOD PICTURE.
SHE HAS
AN INCREDIBLE FACE,
BUT I THINK SHE NEEDS
A LITTLE BIT OF SELF-CONFIDENCE.
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
THANK YOU.
YOU TOO.
I'M FAILING MISERABLY
AT MODELING.
♪♪♪
HI.
HELLO.
HOW'S IT GOING?
I'M NICOLE.
SO YOU'VE DONE
THE PREPPY LOOK.
YOU'RE DOING KIND OF
AVANT-GARDE FASHION THERE.
I'M NOT REALLY FEELING
HER VIBE.
I DON'T REALLY THINK THAT
SHE IS REALLY FEELING ME.
NOT AT ALL
PREPPY.
NOT BY ANY CONSCIOUS
INTERPRETATION OF PREPPY.
♪♪♪
THE THINGS I DO
FOR "ANTM."
RIGHT-- STOP.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DOING ANY OF THIS--
THIS--
THIS THING.
SO, OF COURSE, I DO
MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND HE TELLS ME,
"STOP."
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THAT
ALL OVER THE BLOODY PLACE.
UNH-UNH,
NO WAY.
OKAY, THAT'S MORE
LIKE IT.
THAT'S IT. PERFECT.
EXCELLENT.
♪♪♪
HI.
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU,
I'M ASHLEY.
NIK-- THE WAY SHE PUT HER
COLORS TOGETHER ARE FANTASTIC.
♪♪♪
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
WE'RE GOING TO DO
TWO DIFFERENT LOOKS FOR YOU.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AN ENGLISH PUNK LOOK,
AND THAT'S MORE OF
A COUTURE PIECE.
PERFECT.
EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT.
THAT'S GOOD.
I'M NOT REALLY LIKE
THAT PUNK OF A PERSON,
BUT I JUST,
LIKE, FELT THE OUTFIT
AND KINDA WENT
WITH IT,
AND HE REALLY LIKED
MY WALK,
SO I WAS HAPPY
ABOUT THAT, DEFINITELY.
♪♪♪
I REALLY, YOU KNOW,
NEED TO STEP UP THINGS,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THERE COULD BE
ANOTHER CHANCE
THAT I'M GOING HOME.
I LIKE THE WAY
YOU PUT THINGS TOGETHER.
HAVE YOU GOT
A PAIR OF SHOES?
THESE ARE THE ONLY ONES
I BROUGHT.
AHH.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT JAYLA
AS A PROFESSIONAL MODEL
WOULDN'T BRING HER OWN
HIGH HEELS.
COULD WE SEE
YOUR WALK?
SURE.
VERY NICE.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I FIND THAT JAYLA'S
JUST TOO STIFF,
AND I THINK THAT SHE STILL
NEEDS TO WORK ON THAT WALK.
AND TODAY,
NO ONE WON THE CHALLENGE.
TODAY,
YOU ALL ARE FAILURES.
HELLO, LADIES,
WELCOME BACK.
I HAVE THE EVALUATION SHEETS
FROM EVERY DESIGNER,
AND IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL CRITIQUE.
NICOLE,
YOU LOOK THE BEST.
NIK, YOU ARE THE MOST
PROFESSIONAL.
JAYLA...
I'D SAY THAT I HAVE
A PRETTY DECENT WALK.
YOU ARE THE WORST RUNWAY WALKER
OVERALL.
BRE, YOUR GENERAL APPEARANCE
WAS LEAST APPRECIATED.
YOUR PHOTOS
ARE NOT STRONG,
BUT YOU ARE VERY, VERY GOOD
AT TAKING DIRECTION.
I CANNOT
DRESS,
BUT, OH, OH, OH--
I TAKE
GOOD DIRECTION.
ALL FOUR DESIGNERS
UNANIMOUSLY AGREED THAT,
NIK,
YOU ARE THE WINNER.
THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
SINCE YOU'VE WON,
YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A HUNDRED FRAMES
FOR A PHOTO SHOOT
TOMORROW,
AND YOU'VE GOT
TO CHOOSE A FRIEND.
I'M GOING
TO CHOOSE NICOLE.
NICOLE, YOU ARE GOING
TO GET 80 FRAMES.
I'M THINKING THAT OBVIOUSLY
THE MORE FRAMES YOU GET,
THE MORE OF AN ADVANTAGE
YOU HAVE.
AS ANOTHER
SURPRISE,
YOU GET TO PICK
A FRIEND AS WELL.
I'LL TAKE
JAYLA.
I GET TO PICK
SOMEONE ELSE.
I HATE BRE, SO OBVIOUSLY
I GRABBED JAYLA.
JAYLA,
YOU GET 60 FRAMES.
LAST, BUT NOT LEAST,
BRE,
- YOU WILL GET...
- FIVE FRAMES.
50 FRAMES, BUT YOU
WILL HAVE TO GO FIRST,
AND YOU CANNOT SEE YOURSELF
IN A MIRROR
PRIOR TO
THE PHOTO SHOOT, OKAY?
I GUESS.
(laughing)
I GET 50 FRAMES AND, OH,
LIFE ONLY GETS BETTER.
I'M NOT ALLOWED TO SEE MYSELF
AFTER I GET MY MAKEUP DONE.
NICE TO MEET
YOU, GIRLS.
BYE!
THEN BRE FINDS OUT
THAT SHE CAN'T LOOK AT HERSELF
IN THE MIRROR BEFORE SHE GOES
ON HER PHOTO SHOOT.
UM...
WHATEVER.
♪♪♪
CAN YOU BUCKLE THAT
FOR ME?
THE TIGHTEST ONE?
NIK HAS NEVER
WRONGED ME,
AND IN FACT,
NIK HAS BEEN PRETTY MUCH
SIDE BY SIDE WITH ME,
YOU KNOW, SINCE WE
CAME OUT TO LONDON.
WITH THE WHOLE
RED BULL SCENARIO
AND THE RED BULL
STORY,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHY IT WAS DONE.
I THINK IT WAS CHILDISH
AND I THINK IT WAS ALSO EVIL.
WHERE'S YOUR STUFF
AT?
YOU DRANK IT.
YOU STOLE IT.
THAT'S STEALING, BRE.
YOUR RED BULLS
ARE GONE.
SO IS
MY GRANOLA.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO DO NOW?
EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKS LIKE
ME AND BRE ARE EXTREMELY CLOSE,
I KNOW THAT SHE IS SUPPOSEDLY
"KEEPING" HER ENEMIES CLOSE,
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
I'M DOING?
♪♪♪
TODAY WE WAKE UP
AND WE'RE TOLD
THAT WE'RE GONNA PAIR UP
INTO TWO GROUPS
AND GO SEE
LONDON.
BRE AND NICOLE ARE,
YOU KNOW,
REALLY, REALLY PISSED OFF
AT EACH OTHER,
AND ME AND NIK
ARE STUCK IN THE MIDDLE.
YEAH.
NO DRAMA,
NO ARGUING.
SAY ONE OF US GOES OUT
WITH NICOLE,
ONE OF US GOES OUT
WITH BRE,
ALL WE'RE GONNA HEAR
IS STUFF ABOUT THE OTHER PERSON.
THE GROUP
IS SO SMALL.
NO ONE NEEDS TO HAVE THE DRAMA
AND THE STRESS FACTOR.
I DON'T WANT TO SPLIT
YOU AND JAYLA UP,
BUT YOU KNOW
THE SITUATION.
I'M SORRY, ME AND NIK
WANT TO GO TOGETHER.
ARE YOU
SERIOUS?
OH,
MY GOODNESS.
DON'T LOOK AT ME,
NICOLE.
YOU KNOW
THAT'S WACK.
♪♪
TODAY WE WAKE UP,
AND WE'RE TOLD THAT WE'RE
GONNA PAIR UP INTO TWO GROUPS
AND GO SEE LONDON.
I'M SORRY, ME AND NIK
WANT TO GO TOGETHER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
BRE AND I
GET STUCK TOGETHER.
I DON'T REALLY WANT
TO BE WITH HER.
NICOLE-- I KNOW SHE IS
NOT LOOKING FORWARD
TO EVEN
BREATHING NEXT TO ME.
I HAD PROBLEMS WITH YOU
IN THE BEGINNING,
AND-- I MEAN,
I GOT OVER THAT.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
BEFORE YOU STARTED HITTING ME.
...THERE'S ONE PERSON
IN THIS HOUSE
THAT I SEVERELY,
SEVERELY DISLIKE
ON THE BORDERLINE
OF HATE.
THAT'S NIK.
THE ONE THING THAT I REALLY,
REALLY HOPE HAPPENS RIGHT NOW
IS THAT SHE KEEPS THE SAME
STUPID FACIAL EXPRESSION
IN ALL
HER PICTURES.
THAT WAY, THEY'RE LIKE,
"HMM. YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU SUCK.
BYE-BYE."
NO, IT'S OKAY.
ALL I CAN SAY IS I DID NOT
COME HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS,
AND I DIDN'T COME HERE
TO MAKE ENEMIES.
I CAME HERE
FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S LIFE.
IT'S A DIRTY WORLD,
YOU KNOW?
AND EVERYONE'S HERE
FOR THEMSELVES.
WHEN ME AND JAYLA GO ON OUR WALK
AROUND LONDON,
SHE JUST WANTED
TO KINDA CLEAR THINGS UP,
AND IT'S
KINDA NICE.
IT DOES KINDA SHOW THAT
SHE'S MATURE IN THAT SENSE.
I'M SURE BRE IS
A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS
ABOUT GOING ON THIS WALK
WITH ME.
BUT I DON'T THINK SHE WANTS
ANY MORE DRAMA.
SHE'S MADE TOO MUCH
OF A FOOL OF HERSELF ALREADY.
IS THERE SOMEWHERE WE COULD STOP
AND GET, LIKE, SOME WINE?
OH, THAT WOULD BE
VERY NICE.
IT SOUNDED SO STUPID.
LIKE, WE WERE ARGUING OVER
ENERGY DRINKS.
THE SITUATION JUST WENT
OUT OF CONTROL.
I WAS WRONG.
IF THE SHOE WAS
ON THE OTHER FOOT,
AND YOU DID THAT
TO ME,
I WOULDN'T HAVE REACTED
ANY DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU WOULD,
AND I PROBABLY WOULDN'T EVEN
BE TALKING RIGHT NOW.
I'D BE SO HURT.
BUT THAT JUST SHOWS THAT
YOU'RE MATURE,
AND I WAS BEING
SO STUPID AND IMMATURE
ABOUT THE SITUATION.
AND I WAS JUST WORKING OFF OF,
LIKE, ANGER AND EMOTIONS
INSTEAD
OF THINKING LOGICALLY.
SO...
WELL,
WHAT'S DONE IS DONE.
BUT I'LL BUY YOU
A WHOLE BUNCH OF RED BULL,
AND I'LL PUT RIBBONS AND BOWS
ON THEM, OKAY?
I'M ACTUALLY
REALLY GLAD THAT
ME AND BRE ENDED UP
GOING OUT TOGETHER BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO LIVE
WITH SOMEONE
WHO I HAVE
THIS, YOU KNOW, DRAMA WITH.
OH,
I HAD A GOOD DAY.
I REALLY HAD
A GOOD DAY.
SO DID I.
I'M GLAD THAT WE ENDED UP
WALKING AROUND AND STUFF
IN LONDON BECAUSE I THINK
WE NEEDED THAT,
AND IT DEFINITELY MADE ME
OPEN UP
AND SAY SOME THINGS
TO HER,
ESPECIALLY LIKE,
"I'M SORRY."
I DON'T WANT
ANY MORE DRAMA.
NEITHER DO I.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT ME AND BRE
WENT TOGETHER, ACTUALLY.
LIKE, WE HAD A GOOD TIME
AND WE GOT OVER OUR DIFFERENCES.
TYRA MAIL.
"YOU NEVER KNOW
WHO'LL BE JUDGING YOU.
WILL YOU BE SARI
TOMORROW?"
S-A-R-I. HMM.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT MEANS
AS ALWAYS.
I'M DREADING TODAY
BECAUSE I HAVE A PHOTO SHOOT.
ON TOP OF THAT,
I DON'T FEEL GOOD.
I HAVE A FEVER
AND A MIGRAINE.
IT DON'T GET NO WORSE
THAN THIS.
I'M SO HOT.
I HAVE A FEVER.
I HAVE CRAMPS.
JAYLA HAD GIVEN ME
SOME MEDICINE,
AND THE MEDICINE
MAKES ME SUPER DROWSY
AND ACTUALLY MAKES
MY MIGRAINE WORSE.
IN HERE, GUYS.
- HEY.
- HELLO.
ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU GIRLS OBVIOUSLY HAVE
HEARD ABOUT BOLLYWOOD, RIGHT?
BOLLYWOOD FILMS ARE KNOWN TO BE
LARGER THAN LIFE.
YOU KNOW,
ORNATE COSTUMES,
LOTS OF COLOR.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
GONNA DO TODAY--
A BOLLYWOOD-STYLE
INSPIRED PHOTO SHOOT.
THERE'S GONNA BE
LOTS OF PEOPLE.
SO THE REAL CHALLENGE HERE
TODAY IS
CAN YOU STAND OUT
IN THE CROWD?
ARE YOU GONNA BRING YOUR FACE
TO THE FOREFRONT
AND BE NOTICED?
OR ARE YOU GONNA
FADE INTO THE BACKGROUND?
NOW YOU GUYS HAD A CHALLENGE
THE OTHER DAY-- WHO WON IT?
NIK.
ALL RIGHT, SO, NIK, YOU
ACTUALLY GET TO GO LAST TODAY,
AND YOU HAVE
A HUNDRED FRAMES,
WHICH MEANS
YOU CAN GET TO SEE
WHAT THE OTHER THREE GIRLS
HAVE DONE
AND YOU GET TO LEARN
FROM IT.
NICOLE,
YOU GET TO GO SECOND LAST.
YOU HAVE
80 FRAMES.
JAYLA, YOU GET TO HAVE
60 FRAMES,
AND YOU GET
TO GO SECOND.
BUT, BRE,
YOU GET TO GO FIRST,
AND YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK
AT YOURSELF
AFTER YOU'VE
COME OUT OF HAIR AND MAKEUP.
SO YOU'VE KINDA GOT EVERYTHING
FIGHTING AGAINST YOU TODAY.
NOW YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
IS SOMEONE THAT YOU MAY KNOW.
BUT WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW IS
THE PERSONAL REASON BEHIND
WHY HE WANTED TO DO
THIS PHOTO SHOOT, ALL RIGHT?
COME ON OUT,
NIGEL.
HI, LADIES.
HI!
HOW ARE YOU?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
SURPRISE.
- THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
- WELL, I KNOW.
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
THE WHOLE BOLLYWOOD THING--
HE'S BEEN WAITING
TO UNDRESS ME FOR DAYS.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
THERE YOU GO.
THERE'S
THE BOLLYWOOD THING.
ANYWAY,
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
FINALLY WE GET
TO WORK TOGETHER.
I'M HALF
SRI LANKAN.
MY MOTHER
IS SRI LANKAN.
MY FATHER IS ENGLISH.
SO THE WHOLE
BOLLYWOOD THEME
AND WHAT INDIA MEANS
TO ENGLAND
IS VERY SORT OF DEEP
IN MY HEART.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
AT FIRST,
BECAUSE NIGEL
IS A JUDGE ON PANEL.
AND IF YOU IMPRESS NIGEL,
IT COULD BE AN AMAZING THING.
BUT IF YOU DON'T, IT COULD BE
A VERY DAMAGING SITUATION.
♪♪♪
BABY,
ARE YOU NOT FEELING GOOD?
ARE YOU SICK?
I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR IT.
YOU HAVE TO PRETEND
TO BE HEALTHY.
I DON'T
FEEL GOOD.
YOU DON'T FEEL
GOOD?
UNH-UNH.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
LIKE YOU GOT A COLD?
I KEEP GETTING FEVERS
AND MIGRAINES.
DID YOU TAKE ANYTHING
FOR YOUR HEADACHE TODAY?
JAYLA GAVE ME SOME BENADRYL,
AND THAT'S ABOUT IT.
BENADRYL?
AND
SOME TYLENOL PM.
WHOEVER GAVE HER
THAT BENADRYL
IS TRYING
TO SCREW HER UP,
BECAUSE SHE IS SO DRAGGY
TODAY AND EXHAUSTED.
YOU SAVE ALL THAT ENERGY
SO WHEN YOU ARE ON SET,
WOW! POW!
IT ALL GOES.
THEN YOU CAN FADE
AND DIE AFTERWARDS, YOU KNOW?
I'M NOT REALLY
FEELING WELL TODAY.
JUST SO HAPPENS THAT
I WOULD ONLY HAVE
50 FRAMES
AT MY PHOTO SHOOT.
I'M NOT ALLOWED
TO LOOK AT MYSELF,
SO I HAVE
NO CLUE WHAT I LOOK LIKE.
REALLY CONCENTRATE
ON THE CAMERA.
WHAT IT IS-- I'M TRYING TO GET
YOU TO REALLY POP FROM WITHIN.
KEEP IN MIND, AGAIN,
YOU ONLY HAVE 50 FRAMES.
KEEP THE FINGERS
LIKE THAT.
EYES TO ME,
EVERYBODY.
LET'S MAKE
BOLLYWOOD HAPPY.
NOW YOU'RE DOING A BIT
OF A TEAPOT THERE.
THAT'S GOOD.
IF BRE HAD WON
THE CHALLENGE,
SHE COULD HAVE USED
THOSE EXTRA 50 FRAMES.
COME ON,
MAKE ME PROUD.
EYES TO ME, BRE,
ALWAYS.
LAST FRAME,
BRE.
REALLY CONCENTRATE,
EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WHOO!
SHOT ONE DOWN!
IT WAS KIND OF HARD
DEALING WITH THE FACT THAT
I COULDN'T GET AS MANY FRAMES
AS THE OTHER GIRLS
AND THAT
I COULDN'T SEE MYSELF.
BRE WAS
NOT HERE TODAY.
BRE LEFT
THE BUILDING.
ACTUALLY, I DON'T THINK BRE
ENTERED THE BUILDING.
OKAY, GUYS.
EVERYBODY FOCUS.
JAYLA, JUST RELAX THE MOUTH
A LITTLE BIT LIKE THAT.
AND JUST CHIN DOWN
AND NOW EYES
TO ME.
REALLY OOZE
WITH YOUR EYES.
I'M JUST GONNA KEEP DOING
WHAT I'M DOING
BECAUSE THE MORE
I THINK ABOUT
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
TO ME,
THE MORE
IT MAKES ME NERVOUS.
NOW TRY
WITH THE FACE MORE.
JAYLA'S EXPRESSION
IS THIS...
AND FOR A TOP MODEL
TO GIVE ME
THAT SAME FLAT, BORING FACE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
HONESTLY STEP OUT
INTO THAT WORLD
WITH ONE EXPRESSION.
JAYLA, I NEED YOUR FACE TO GO
FROM JUST PRETTY
TO HAVING THAT
LITTLE EXTRA SOMETHING
THAT MAKES
PEOPLE GO "WOW."
EVEN THOUGH JAYLA'S
A VERY PRETTY GIRL--
SHE GETS MADE UP,
SHE LOOKS AMAZING--
BUT I DIDN'T FEEL THAT SHE WAS
REALLY HAVING FUN WITH IT.
OWN THIS SHOT.
THERE YOU GO,
JAYLA.
I GOT THE SAME COMMENTS
THAT I GET
EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF MY PHOTO SHOOTS.
SO I'M LIKE, "OH, GREAT,
MY PHOTO SHOOT SUCKS."
I THINK EVERYONE WANTS TO DO
ESPECIALLY WELL TODAY
BECAUSE NIGEL
IS A JUDGE.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GO.
SERIOUS FACES
ALL AROUND,
EYES ARE THE ONLY THING
THAT GLITTER.
BEAUTIFUL.
JAY, LET'S
HAVE SOME FAN.
TURN THAT FAN UP HIGH
FOR ME, PLEASE.
ALL IN THE EYES,
PLEASE.
CAN YOU COME
EVEN FURTHER DOWN?
GORGEOUS.
MAKES YOU LOOK
MORE RELAXED.
I DIDN'T THINK THAT NICOLE
WAS REALLY GONNA BE
AS GOOD
AS SHE WAS.
NO FAN, THOUGH.
CAN WE RELEASE
THAT FAN?
FOR ME, SHE REALLY
STEPPED UP HER GAME,
AND WHAT THIS COMPETITION
IS ABOUT
IS ABOUT STEPPING UP YOUR GAME
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
NOT BECAUSE OF NIGEL
OR ANYTHING,
'CAUSE I'LL
BE DAMNED
IF I GONNA BLOW
HIS HEAD UP BIGGER THAN IT IS.
BUT, NICOLE, THAT WAS, LIKE,
YOUR BEST SHOOT EVER.
TRY AND GIVE ME
SOMETHING PRETTY FACE ON.
OKAY.
ARE WE READY?
GORGEOUS.
REALLY
MOVING WELL.
REALLY MOVING
WELL.
NICE, GUYS.
EVERYBODY'S DOING
A GOOD JOB.
NIK HAD
THE HUNDRED FRAMES.
SHOT NUMBER ONE--
GORGEOUS.
SHOT NUMBER TWO-- GORGEOUS.
SHOT NUMBER THREE--
FLAWLESS.
NIK DIDN'T EVEN NEED
THOSE EXTRA FRAMES TODAY.
OKAY, GUYS,
LAST FRAME.
WHOO--
ALL RIGHT!
WE FINISH
THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND WE'RE TOLD THAT WE ARE GOING
OUT TO DINNER TONIGHT.
IT'S DEFINITELY MY FIRST TIME
IN AN INDIAN RESTAURANT.
BUT I'M JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO, YOU KNOW, NEW THINGS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HEAR OUR SPECIALS?
HEY, LADIES.
HI, NIGEL.
HOW
ARE YA?
GOOD.
I'M GOING TO BE ONE OF
YOUR OTHER GUESTS TONIGHT.
IT'S A FUN
SURPRISE.
IT'S REALLY COOL THAT WE GET
TO SEE NIGEL AWAY FROM PANEL.
AND HE IS ACTUALLY
HUMAN TO US NOW.
MY MOTHER IS
FROM SRI LANKA,
AND SHE WAS ALSO
A MODEL
AND SHE BROUGHT HER FAMILY OVER
FROM SRI LANKA
TO ENGLAND BECAUSE OF THE MONEY
SHE MADE FROM MODELING.
AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO MY MOTHER.
SHE'S GONNA
HAVE DINNER WITH US.
MUM--
THIS IS MY MOTHER.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
THIS IS A LOVELY TREAT
FOR ME.
I GET TO SPEND TIME
WITH NIGEL.
EXACTLY.
I WAS BORN IN BOMBAY,
WHICH IS NOW CALLED MUMBAI.
I STARTED
MY SINGING CAREER AT 14.
AND THEN I WON
A MODELING COMPETITION AS WELL.
YOU'VE GOT TO FOLLOW YOUR HEART
AND LEARN AS MUCH AS YOU CAN,
BECAUSE THAT WILL STAND YOU
IN GOOD STEAD.
I ENJOYED HAVING
DINNER WITH NIGEL AND HIS MOM.
SHE KIND OF MAKES ME
FEEL A LOT BETTER.
YOU GUYS ALL SAW SARIS TODAY,
DIDN'T YOU?
PERHAPS YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW THEM
HOW TO PUT ON THE SARI.
YES.
NOW A SARI IS MADE UP
OF 6 YARDS OF MATERIAL,
AND IT'S VERY EASY TO DRAPE
ONCE YOU GET THE HANG OF IT.
NIGEL'S MOTHER IS TEACHING US
HOW TO WEAR SARIS.
I'M DEFINITELY PAYING ATTENTION
BECAUSE FOR SOME REASON,
I FEEL LIKE SOMEHOW THIS IS
GONNA COME BACK LATER ON.
SEE HOW ELEGANT
YOU LOOK?
SO THERE YOU GO,
GUYS.
THAT'S THE SECRETS
TO THE SARI.
GOOD NIGHT.
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU
WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
"IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
"ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED.
"TYRA."
"X-O. X-O, TYRA."
COME ON, NOW,
READ IT RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WOULD KNOW WHETHER
I WAS DOING GOOD OR DOING BAD
IF I UNDERSTOOD WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH THE JUDGES' HEADS.
I HONESTLY NEVER REALLY FEEL
THAT COMFORTABLE
WHERE I AM
IN THE COMPETITION.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WOULD REALLY SUCK
TO BE SENT HOME RIGHT NOW.
WHY AM I
STILL HERE?
I MADE IT
TO THE TOP FOUR.
I MAY NOT BE HERE TOMORROW, BUT
WHETHER WE REALIZE THIS OR NOT.
I'M THE FOURTH BADDEST BITCH
IN AMERICA,
AND AIN'T NOBODY
TAKING THAT AWAY FROM ME.
♪♪♪
I HAVE BEEN DRAGGED
THROUGH THE DIRT
EVERY SINGLE
ELIMINATION.
FIRST TIME I WAS IN
THE BOTTOM TWO,
I WAS SHOCKED.
WILL DIANE AND BRE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
SECOND TIME I WAS
IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
I FELT
DEFEATED.
WILL BRE AND KYLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
THIRD TIME I WAS IN
THE BOTTOM TWO,
I COMPLETELY
WENT NUMB,
AND I JUST WANTED
TO DIE.
WILL BRE AND KIM
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I AM THE UNDERDOG OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GONNA WIN
THIS COMPETITION,
BUT DO I DESERVE
TO WIN THE COMPETITION?
YES.
WELCOME,
LADIES.
YOU GUYS
LOOK LOVELY.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE OUR
NINTH CUT,
WHICH WILL
BRING US ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
AND, OF COURSE,
WE HAVE LOVELY DOVELY PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS
A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN
"ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE
SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON
AND A COVER OF
"ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE,
WHICH HITS STANDS
IN FEBRUARY, 2006.
AND LAST,
BUT NOT LEAST,
A CONTRACT WORTH $100,000
FROM COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW
OUR JUDGES...
MR. NIGEL BARKER...
HI, LADIES.
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT SHOT YOU THIS WEEK.
LEGENDARY, LOVELY
MISS
J. ALEXANDER,
YOUR RUNWAY COACH.
MISS TWIGGY,
FASHION ICON.
AND BARBARA HULANICKI.
BARBARA IS THE CREATOR
AND DESIGNER OF BIBA,
AND BARBARA PUT MOD ON THE MAP
SINGLE-HANDEDLY.
NOW THIS WEEK
YOU GUYS LEARNED ABOUT
FOUR INFLUENTIAL FASHIONS,
DID YOU NOT?
YOU'RE GONNA BE PUT
TO THE TEST.
THERE IS AN ITEM THAT HAS
INSPIRED LONDON DESIGNERS
THAT WAITS IN THE BACK FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
TO TAKE THAT ITEM
AND UPDATE IT
TO MODERN FASHION.
ARE YOU READY?
GO!
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY.
FIRST IS NICOLE.
SO, NICOLE, YOU HAD TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE SARI
THAT'S MODERN.
GIVE A LITTLE TWIRL,
DARLING.
LITTLE TWIRL.
I LIKE THAT
THE BOOTY'S OUT.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU FELL IN
THE CURTAINS OR SOMETHING.
ALL WRAPPED UP
LIKE A CAT,
LIKE RAWR!
YOU'RE COVERING TOO MUCH
OF YOURSELF.
I'M WITH NIGEL.
I WOULD JUST TAKE
EVERYTHING OFF
AND JUST
TIE IT UP.
SO WHEN
YOU TURNED ROUND,
WE GOT BARE BACK
AND A LITTLE BUTT CLEAVAGE.
THEN IT WOULD
BE GOOD.
WHY ARE YOU
SO HORNY?
WELL,
YOU KNOW...
ALL RIGHTY, NICOLE,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WELL, FOR ME,
YOU PHOTOGRAPHED
ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE COMPETITION BRILLIANTLY.
I MEAN, YOU ARE VERY,
VERY PHOTOGENIC.
I DON'T SEE NOTHING REALLY
INTENSE ABOUT THAT PICTURE.
I JUST--
REALLY?
SHE COULD BE
MUCH MORE BEAUTIFUL, PERSONALLY,
FOR ME,
UP CLOSE.
I HAVE TO 100% DISAGREE
WITH MISS J.
YOU HAVE NEVER HAD
THIS MUCH RANGE.
I MEAN,
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO CHOOSE.
YOU HAD ONE WHERE
YOU WERE LIKE THIS
AND THEN LIKE THIS,
AND THEN LIKE THIS
AND THEN--
I WAS LIKE,
GIRL, YOU BETTER WORK.
THIS IS
YOUR BEST.
MAMA IS PROUD
OF YOU.
MM-HMM.
I LOVE IT.
ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS BRE.
WELL, I DON'T
REALLY KNOW.
BUT IT LOOKS THE MOST
TRADITIONALLY SARI-ISH.
IT'S NOT
A MODERN TAKE.
IT IS ACTUALLY
VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD,
AND HEY,
THAT'S YOU.
AND NO SHOES.
NO SHOES.
ALL RIGHT,
BRE.
SO YOU GUYS
HAD A PHOTO SHOOT THIS WEEK
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE A FACE
IN A CROWD.
HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
WELL, ACTUALLY
YOU DO JUMP OUT.
MY EYES WENT STRAIGHT
TO YOU.
IF THAT WAS THE CHALLENGE,
YOU GOT IT, GIRL.
OOH, I SOUNDED
ALL AMERICAN THEN.
BRE, BECAUSE YOU ARE
A LITTLE BIT SHORTER
THAN
THE AVERAGE MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER YOUR NECK
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONE THING
THAT MAKES THIS PHOTO NOT A TEN,
IS THAT YOUR NECK
LOOKS SHORT.
JAY SAID THAT YOU WEREN'T
THE SAME BRE
THAT HE'S USED
TO SEEING
AND DON'T TAKE A BENADRYL
BEFORE A PHOTO SHOOT.
IT'LL MAKE YOU
TIRED.
YOU TOOK
A BENADRYL?
I THOUGHT IT WAS, LIKE,
AN ALLERGY--
LIKE A SINUS
INFECTION,
AND SO ONE OF THE GIRLS
GAVE ME A BENADRYL.
YOU LET A GIRL
GIVE YOU A PILL?
YOUR COMPETITION?
NO, IT WAS--
(laughter)
YOU LET YOUR COMPETITION
GIVE YOU A PILL, GIRL?
BUT I DON'T HAVE
ANY MEDICINE
TO TAKE
WHILE I'M OUT HERE,
AND I KEEP GETTING SICK,
SO...
MM-HMM.
UP NEXT IS NIK.
TO ME, THAT'S THE KIND
OF MOST MODERN, UNIQUE WAY OF--
I WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN
IT WAS A SARI, ACTUALLY.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU
ONE THING,
YOU PICKED A COLOR THAT'S
GOOD FOR YOUR SKIN.
YOU'VE GOT A MODERN TWIST
ON SOMETHING.
I THINK
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT, NIK,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO STAND OUT
IN A CROWD,
AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE 'CAUSE IT'S GOT
THAT KIND OF--
YOU'VE DONE, LIKE,
THAT INDIAN DANCERS DO
WITH THE HEAD.
IT'S LOVELY.
OH, LIKE,
PUSHED IT TO THE SIDE?
ISOLATION.
THAT'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE TO ME.
TO ME, A PHOTOGRAPH IS
THE EYES,
AND HER EYES
ARE FANTASTIC.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE FIRST THING
YOU LOOK AT.
YOU WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
YOU WON THE CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK.
WHICH MEANT THAT YOU GOT
A HUNDRED FRAMES,
AND THAT WORKED,
BECAUSE YOUR FILM
WAS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
IN FACT, YOU DIDN'T NEED
THAT MANY FRAMES,
TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
WHY IS EVERYBODY SEEING THAT,
AND I'M AIN'T SEEING IT?
GIVE YOU
SOME GLASSES.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS JAYLA.
SO, JAYLA, YOU HAD TO MAKE
A SARI MODERN,
AND YOU PUT ABOUT 20 POUNDS
OF WEIGHT ON YOUR BODY.
HOW DID YOU MANAGE
TO DO THAT?
YOU SHOULD HAVE WRAPPED IT
AND WRAPPED IT AND WRAPPED IT
TILL YOU
COULDN'T BREATHE.
IT WAS LIKE THAT,
BUT I THINK IT FELL.
YOU WALKED IN
LIKE THAT.
BUT I THINK THE COLOR
IS FANTASTIC.
SHE'S BEING A GOOD MAMA
OVER THERE,
AND TRYING TO GIVE
HER BABY SOMETHING POSITIVE.
ALL RIGHT,
JAYLA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WHERE IS SHE?
YOU DON'T STAND OUT
AS MUCH AS I WOULD'VE LIKED.
AND SHE IS SPECIALLY LIT, TOO,
TO POP.
WELL, I GUESS SINCE
SHE DIDN'T POP, SHE POOPED.
THE TWO OF THEM
WERE STANDING SO CLOSE TO ME.
WHEN I WAS STANDING THERE
AND, LIKE,
PRACTICING MY POSITIONS,
I KEPT ALMOST
HITTING THEM IN THE FACE.
THAT'S JUST WHAT
I WOULD HAVE DONE,
STRETCHED MY HANDS RIGHT ACROSS
THEIR FACES.
BECAUSE IT WAS
YOUR PICTURE.
YEAH, I WAS AFRAID TO,
LIKE, GET IN THEIR WAY.
IT'S YOUR
PICTURE.
YES, YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO SAY,
"YOU'RE
MY BACKUP DANCERS,
"NOW BACK UP,
BITCHES."
AND YOU SHOULD'VE
OFFERED THEM A BENADRYL.
OOH!
THANKS,
JAYLA.
THANK YOU.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL
YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
NOW IT'S TIME
TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE
OF THESE GIRLS SHOULD GO HOME.
BRE.
I'M A BIT THROWN
BECAUSE BRE DIDN'T PHOTOGRAPH
VERY WELL
IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE COMPETITION, FOR ME.
BUT THIS WEEK,
AND LAST WEEK,
HER PHOTOGRAPHS HAVE BEEN
BEAUTIFUL.
THIS IS, YOU KNOW,
A COMPETITION ABOUT IMPROVING.
SO I THINK
IT IS A GOOD THING
THAT SHE'S
FINALLY TAKING GREAT PICTURES.
BRE IS GROWING, BUT SHE'S
NOT GROWING IN HEIGHT.
AND SHE'S NOT GONNA GET
ANY TALLER.
THAT'S A GIRL THAT SHOULD
NEVER TAKE OFF HER SHOES,
EVEN WHEN SHE SLEEPS.
SHE'S SHORT.
JAYLA.
JAYLA FELT VERY WEAK
FOR ME TODAY.
I KEEP SEEING SOMETHING
IN JAYLA
AND THEN NOT SEEING
SOMETHING.
AND THEN
I SAW SOMETHING,
AND THEN JUST SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE LINE TODAY,
SHE DISAPPEARED.
BY HERSELF,
SHE'S STUNNING.
SHE'S GOT CLASSIC LOOKS,
YOU KNOW,
BEAUTIFUL BLUE EYES.
I THINK
SHE'S A GODDESS.
SHE'S GORGEOUS.
I FEEL LIKE JAYLA
IS SHRINKING.
I FEEL LIKE SHE HAD
SUCH STRONG CONFIDENCE
IN THE BEGINNING,
AND AS THE COMPETITION IS
GETTING TIGHTER,
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
I'M LOOKING AT HER,
AND SHE'S, LIKE, GOING,
"TYRA, WHY AM I STILL HERE?"
BUT I REALLY BELIEVE
IN THIS GIRL.
I BELIEVE IN HER
SO MUCH.
NICOLE.
NICOLE MANAGED TO COME TO SET
AND LIGHT IT UP.
LIGHT IT UP?
I JUST DON'T
SEE HER LIT.
I THINK SHE'S
A FABULOUS LOOKING GIRL.
(British accent)
SHE'S PRETTY, SHE'S GORGEOUS,
SHE TAKES
A NICE PHOTO.
(normal voice)
NIK.
WELL, I THINK
SHE'S GORGEOUS.
THIS IS THE BEAUTY
OF ALL TIME.
THIS GIRL IS GOING TO BE
A SUPER, SUPER STAR.
HER MAIN PROBLEMS
ARE--
THAT I DON'T THINK SHE HAS
THAT BITCHY ELEMENT
AND SHE'S
LACKING THE SEX APPEAL.
BUT SHE DOES TAKE
A GOOD PICTURE.
SHE DOES.
BUT PROFESSIONAL MODELS
ALL TAKE GOOD PICTURES.
OF COURSE,
THAT'S THE JOB.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE
THAT'S THAT SPECIAL SOMETHING
THAT TIPS
THE BALANCE?
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S GETTING
SO TRICKY NOW, RIGHT?
IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT.
FOUR BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
THREE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE THREE OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NICOLE.
YOU'VE TAKEN A PRETTY PICTURE
FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
NIK.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING
WHEN I CALLED YOUR NAME?
I SAW YOU EXHALE.
I JUST KNOW IT'S NOT THAT MANY
GIRLS' NAMES TO BE CALLED,
SO IT'S JUST A NERVE-RACKING,
YOU KNOW, WAIT UP THERE.
IT'S SCARY.
YOU HAVE SHOWN THAT YOU CAN BE
A MODEL
AND WORK.
BUT IT'S UP TO YOU
AND NICOLE
TO SHOW
WAY MORE PERSONALITY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL JAYLA AND BRE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL CALL
ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
BACK TO YOUR HOTEL,
PACK YOUR
BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
BRE, YOU STARTED OFF
ROUGH.
YOU WANTED TO TAKE
A GOOD PICTURE
BUT COULDN'T REALLY TAKE
A FIERCE PICTURE
TO SAVE
YOUR LIFE.
BUT YOU HAVE PROGRESSED,
YOU HAVE LEARNED.
YOU HAVE ABSORBED
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
LIKE A SPONGE
AND HAVE IMPROVED.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING LACKING
WITH YOU, BRE,
AND THAT'S
HEIGHT.
AND THE JUDGES JUST AREN'T SURE
THAT YOUR AMAZING PROGRESS
IS ENOUGH
TO OVERCOME THAT.
JAYLA,
YOU HAD A VIVACIOUS, STRONG,
GREAT PERSONALITY
WHEN YOU CAME
IN HERE,
BUT SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
YOU DON'T BELIEVE
IN YOURSELF ANYMORE.
WE SEE THE DOUBT
WHEN YOU WALK IN HERE.
TOP MODELS
AREN'T SHORT
AND THEY DEFINITELY
DON'T DOUBT THEMSELVES.
BRE.
BRE, TO COMPENSATE
FOR YOUR LACK OF HEIGHT,
YOU NEED TO BE MORE STRIKING
AND THAT MUCH MORE PERSONABLE.
BUT WE SEE A LITTLE SOMETHING
SPECIAL IN YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANKS, JAYLA.
I'M EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED.
I ALWAYS TRIED
MY HARDEST.
I GUESS I'M FEELING
A LITTLE BIT OF A MIXTURE
OF SADNESS,
SURPRISE.
THAT KIND OF THING.
I'M GONNA TRY
TO SHADOW THE WINNER,
I AM GOING TO
MAKE HER LOOK LIKE NOTHING.
THAT IS
MY GOAL.
I MADE IT
TO THE TOP THREE.
THE VERY LAST CHANCE
TO PROVE YOURSELF
TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
JUST MAKES ME REALLY WANT
TO WIN, LIKE, SO BAD.
'CAUSE
I'M ALMOST THERE.
I'M JUST VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT I MADE IT TO THIS MOMENT.
I WANT
TO WIN THIS.
THIS IS WHAT
I CAME HERE FOR.
GOOD LUCK.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE FINISH LINE IS IN SIGHT
AS THE FINAL THREE
GET READY FOR
THEIR COVER GIRL CLOSE-UP...
COVER GIRL.
WITH A PHOTO SHOOT
AND A COMMERCIAL
STANDING BETWEEN THEM
AND THEIR FINAL CHALLENGE.
YOU MAY THINK YOU KNOW
WHO IS GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL,
BUT YOU REALLY DON'T.
WHO WILL RULE
THE FINAL RUNWAY
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
FIND OUT
ON OUR SEASON FINALE.